delicious food for a great cause golden
rainbow's dining out for life is
happening tomorrow night and here to
tell us all about it is gary costa with
gold and rainbow and we got summer rich
with salud mexican bistro welcome you
guys well thank you so much for having
us first off gary tell us about golden
rainbow and however tomorrow night how
it benefits you guys right golden
rainbow is an organization that provides
housing and emergency financial support
for people living with hiv here in
southern nevada we were founded by the
las vegas entertainment community during
the aids epidemic and now we're finding
ourselves having to respond to this new
epidemic kobet tomorrow's night's event
is going to help raise additional monies
to help those people that are going to
be displaced and lose their homes
because of the moratorium eviction
and and so we've provided housing for
people with hiv to continue to live you
guys are doing great things here in the
valley so tomorrow night summer everyone
comes to a restaurant they make a
reservation what time will we come in
tomorrow from 5 to 9 00 pm at salud
mexican bistro they can either make a
reservation at slootmexicanbistro.com or
they can do
702-665-6423 either way we'll have a
seat available for them and you have
delicious food you brought delicious
food to show us here today and also some
amazing drinks what are you gonna have
on tap for us tomorrow night on tap we
have a full bar yeah
um what i did make uh today was our uh
demon gummy shot so it's i've got a
little special surprise on the inside
and this is there's a gummy bear inside
there right there okay
so i do have that one and that's with
our demon and then we have an embargo
door uh
mark uh what do you call it oh i just
put it in the wrong one shake every
margarita and summers you're shaking
that together you worked with golden
rainbow before i have when i was younger
i used to dance for them when i was in
the shows i was in efx with michael
crawford
yes yep bill acosta's lasting
impressions so i was able to provide uh
my donation in that way and now it's
come a full circle and i have a
restaurant with my dad and so we were
able to provide it this way for them so
it's just been really really nice to be
able to to continue to help the
community this is fantastic and just
real quick as we get ready to wrap up
talk about the food that you guys have
here so this is our tequila
fettuccine alfredo and this one is our
flank steak with a cheese inch latta and
then we've got charo beans and uh cactus
with um jalapenos and so the last
question for you is the reason why is
this so important to you this is
important to me because i mean aids just
being a dancer and a performer my whole
life it's been prevalent in in
in the industry forever and i just any
way that i can give back in any way
shape or form is just really important
to me summer we appreciate it you
joining us well gary appreciate it why
don't you do the shot gary you have a
busy night tomorrow night all right i'll
take the drink and then you take the
shot gary and
we'll uh we'll celebrate thank you so
much for joining us we appreciate it
thank you summer so dining out for life
is happening tomorrow night at salud
mexican bistro from five to nine you did
that shot
you can make reservations online at
salud mexican bistro dot com or call 702
655 here have that
mention golden rainbow when making
reservations and we'll be right back